not a lot of people are thinking about
this especially when it comes to the
last two seasons of
the bachelor franchise but you had to
quarantine and self-isolate for quite a
long time before you even
got on the show so what was it like for
you finally getting to start your
journey with matt
um yeah definitely so we got there and
you know quarantine isolation was a huge
part of it but that just made it
so much more rewarding to start the
journey of the bachelor because
you know we knew we were all so safe
going into
night one and it just it made it a lot
easier to just relax
and totally take advantage of what was
in front of us
now speaking of night one you had i'm
gonna say one of the boldest
limo entrances it was so great watching
you have that lady in the [ __ ] moment i
mean what was that whole when you look
back on that
what what did you think i mean
it was definitely bold even for me i
like to think i'm a bold person but that
was really putting myself out there
um you know it might be cuter
when two cartoon dogs do it
no way but um yeah i thought it was cute
and i'm happy i did it
oh i'm so happy you did it it was great
we're like that you want something
that's memorable and that was definitely
memorable what was your conversation
like with matt
oh he's just you know such a nice person
i have to be honest with you though i
was so
nervous i'm pretty sure i blacked out
talking to him
i don't entirely remember what i said
but i do remember him just making me
feel at ease and
like we were kind of in this for the
first time together
so there was less to worry about
well you know the audience was getting
to know matt for the first time
matt's never been on any of the seasons
in the bachelor franchise
so do you think that that has helped his
journey or do you think that hinders it
a little bit
you know personally i'm gonna go with
help because i think that he has
you know less to sway
how he deals with this and it's really
just coming from the heart as he moves
forward
um you know you have all these ideas of
how bachelor's gonna play out but when
you're actually
in in the the mansion or i guess in your
case in the really fancy hotel um
what was the whole experience like for
you was it what you thought
well when i went into it i thought i
would be leaving with a fiance so it's
definitely not what i thought
but um there were a lot of other great
things that came of it you know i wasn't
there for long but i made great
connections with the girls
um you definitely think you're gonna go
on some dates i didn't go on anything
but you know the experience i
really enjoyed it and i have connections
from it that i'll have forever
i love that okay so obviously a lot of
people are talking about victoria this
season
i want to know from your perspective is
what we see on camera
actually what she's like in real life
when the cameras aren't rolling
well you know i mean editing can only do
so much um
you are filming for
you know several days for an episode and
the public only gets to see two hours
so it's really just the highlights but
again editing can only do
so much so you're saying she's
similar in real life as who we see on
camera
yes okay perfect what's your take on the
whole
marilyn and victoria drama that broke my
heart
um yeah i mean marilyn is such a
sweetheart and so
it was hard to see her get
stuck in that um you know it would have
been nice had
the two girls just been able to solve it
themselves and not involve
math um especially so early on in
the process of the show yeah it was
early
yeah very early and you know it's i just
think it's really unfortunate that it
had to happen at all
yeah um is did anything else happen
while you were there that didn't make it
on camera that you're surprised
didn't make on camera anything that was
kind of fun or juicy
honestly the majority of the time that i
was there was
victoria oh i'm not surprised at all
with what's made it to air
that's amazing i love that okay so you
know i'm sure people have been asking
this
um you know we were so sad to see you go
would you ever be
interested in doing something like
bachelor in paradise
i definitely would um i think that you
know
i'd love to have a bachelor date under
my belt
and so yes that would be nice um but
we'll see what the future holds
but yeah so you because obviously that's
a bit of a different show than the
bachelor so you would you'd be game
if they approached you i'd be game maybe
i'd
be more into like having multiple
options and just being one of many
options
i like that i like that so would you
change anything that you did while you
were on the bachelor
no i really wouldn't um you know i had
an okay amount of time to talk to matt
and we just didn't really vibe that way
and that's okay and i was myself and so
i'm really happy with
how i behaved and acted and everything
that's a good feeling because sometimes
you can't always control how you're
portrayed on camera right you can't
control the editors are doing so it's
nice that you feel good about
how you came across yeah definitely okay
who
do you think has the strongest with uh
strongest connection with matt so far
well watching it i mean i'm going off
with one-on-one dates
and i would have said sarah but she's
not there anymore so
after seeing serena pee's one-on-one
date i'm gonna have to go with serena p
yeah definitely chemistry and it was
it's just like fun it was a fun
light-hearted you know kind of chemistry
that they have um
who is your prediction then who do you
think will make it to the final rose
oh my gosh that's such a hard question
you know there's girls that you can tell
have a great connection with him right
off the bat
if he abigail you know i really think
that
any of them could get really close to
the end and you know
we're so early on in the season he's
gonna make
deeper connections with more girls as we
go so
it's it'll be interesting to see now do
you enjoy watching this show back or
does it sting a little now that you're
not there
and you kind of you know obviously still
wish you were there
i actually think it's the opposite i
think that watching the episodes i was
on
were more nerve-wracking and now i'm not
on it i'm like okay where's the popcorn
like yeah
i love that get the wine now you can
actually enjoy it you have to worry
about it i love that
well i i'm so happy we got to have you
on the few episodes that we did
you uh you wrecked canada well uh so
yeah it's so great getting to talk to
you yeah i'm a huge fan so i cannot wait
to see who matt's gonna pick
now i'm so excited
you